[Música]
en tan solo horas los colombianos
asistirán a las urnas para elegir
presidente más de 39 millones de
personas están llamadas a votar de
acuerdo con el ministerio de defensa
unos 300.000 miembros de la fuerza
pública fueron desplegados en todo el
país para garantizar la seguridad en la
cita electoral analizamos la
participación de los jóvenes
en eeuu las autoridades investigan la
respuesta tardía de la policía de texas
al tiroteo en la escuela de uralde que
dejó veintiuna personas muertas e
indagar sobre las motivaciones del
atacante la vicepresidenta- kamala
harris hizo un llamado a la prohibición
de armas de asalto tras asistir al
funeral de una de las víctimas del
tiroteo en buffalo
méxico confirma su primer caso de
viruela del mono de acuerdo con las
autoridades sanitarias se trata de un
hombre que probablemente contrajo el
virus en países bajos este es el segundo
país de américa latina en reportar un
contagio por la enfermedad después de
argentina tenemos reporte desde ciudad
de mexico
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz iniciamos en colombia
porque en tan solo cuestión de horas se
espera que más de 39 millones de
personas acudan a las urnas para elegir
a su nuevo presidente unos 300.000
miembros de la fuerza pública fueron
desplegados en todo el país para
garantizar la seguridad en la cita
electoral una población determinante en
estos comicios son los jóvenes pues
desde el estallido social de 2019 son
cada vez más los que han venido
presionando por un cambio previamente
hablamos con mateo ortiz investigador
del observatorio javeriano de juventudes
en bogotá quien nos contó que se espera
de los jóvenes en estas elecciones
yo creo que sí yo creo que las y los
jóvenes van a participar más en es de
dos comisiones electorales precisamente
por las condiciones históricas que
estamos viendo como país aún así que
vaya a ser un incremento significativo
de la participación no lo creería
particularmente porque no sólo los
jóvenes sino toda la población tiene una
fuerte desconfianza por el sistema
representativo que estamos teniendo en
colombia muy pocas personas confían en
la presidencia en el congreso y esto
pasa también en los jóvenes muy pocos de
ellos o sea ninguna de sus instancias
representativas supera el 20 por ciento
de confianza en las los jóvenes por lo
que yo creería que la participación en
esos comicios se incrementará
precisamente por el momento histórico
que estamos viviendo pero no será
significativamente mayor cambiamos de
tema mientras rusia intensifica su
ofensiva para hacerse con el control de
las principales ciudades del donbass el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
calificó la situación como
indescriptiblemente difícil sin embargo
mostró optimismo al decir que su
gobierno está trabajando para aumentar
los suministros de armas que se acercaba
al punto en que superaría el número a
los rusos tanto tecnológicamente como en
términos de su capacidad de ataque
el día 94 de la guerra a gran escala
terminó especialmente en aquellas áreas
en la región del donbass y kharkiv donde
el ejército ruso está tratando de
obtener al menos algún resultado las
áreas claves de lucha en el frente
siguen siendo severo ni es liz chang
ivac nuts bopanna y otras ciudades donde
se concentra la ofensiva rusa o morona
tremens y en oval de continúan las
conmemoraciones por la muerte de los 19
niños y dos profesoras en la escuela
rock el martes pasado este homenaje se
mezcla con el funeral de las víctimas
del tiroteo en un supermercado de búfalo
donde fueron asesinadas 13 personas la
vicepresidenta que ama la harris quien
asistió al sepelio dijo que la violencia
por las armas ya era suficiente andrés
gana de ello nos cuenta más
la masacre de la escuela primaria en
texas es una herida abierta en la ciudad
los sobrevivientes familiares y sus
pobladores lloran a sus víctimas a media
mañana de este sábado varias docenas de
personas se reunieron en la plaza del
juzgado de baldi para recordar a los que
perdieron la vida alrededor de una
fuente han puesto 21 cruces blancas una
por cada víctima
me da rabia pero también veo todo el
amor y la gente que viene aquí quiero
que vean que si están sufriendo y están
pensando en hacer una locura o si saben
de alguien que va a hacer algo así por
favor ayuda en lo que piden ayuda
buscando ayuda para alguien porque esto
no vuelva a pasar
pero no sólo este tiroteo tiene enlutado
a eeuu hace dos semanas hubo una
balacera en el supermercado de búfalo
cuando 13 personas perdieron la vida la
vicepresidenta kamala harris que fue al
funeral mostró su rechazo a todos los
hechos de violencia relacionados con
armas de fuego
lo que pasó aquí en búfalo en texas en
atlanta en orlando lo que pasó en las
sinagogas este es un momento que
requiere que todas las buenas personas
todas las personas que aman a dios se
pongan de pie y digan no toleraremos
esto
[Aplausos]
suficiente es suficiente nos uniremos
con base a lo que todos sabemos que
tenemos en común y no permitiremos que
esas personas que están motivadas por el
odio nos separen o nos hagan sentir
miedo
en winston benjamín hernández un hombre
que le pidió una foto al senador
republicano ted cruz en restaurante
aprovechó el momento para confrontarlo y
decirle que 19 niños murieron yo acuso
de ser responsable por su apoyo al corte
de armas
cruz asistió el viernes a la convención
de la asociación nacional del rifle en
su discurso acusó a las élites ya los
medios de comunicación de ir en contra
de la segunda enmienda que protege el
derecho de las personas a comprar y
portar armas después de argentina-méxico
se convirtió en el segundo país de
américa latina en confirmar un caso
positivo de la viruela del mono según
informó la organización mundial de la
salud más de 200 contagios se han
reportado en unos 20 países de todo el
mundo donde el virus no es endémico
desde ciudad de méxico nuestro
corresponsal mario' carbonell con los
detalles
en méxico se tiene ya de manera oficial
detectado el primer caso importado de
viruela del mono el subsecretario de
salud federal hugo lópez gatell informó
que se trata de un hombre de 50 años de
edad con residencia permanente en la
ciudad de nueva york y quien pudo
haberse contagiado durante su presencia
en países bajos
el paciente se atiende en la ciudad de
mexico se encuentra estable está en
aislamiento preventivo y su diagnóstico
fue confirmado a través de una prueba
pcr dos días antes de la detección de
este primer caso la secretaria de salud
había ya emitido la alerta
epidemiológica para que todos los
hospitales y clínicas del país estén
pendientes de pacientes que presenten
fiebre alta dolor de cabeza intenso
dolor muscular en la espalda y piernas y
fatiga extrema esto durante los cinco
primeros días y después pendiente de la
presencia de salpullido y de erupciones
en la piel que comienzan en el rostro y
se diseminan por todo el cuerpo lópez
gatell dijo que este virus no se propaga
por el aire ni por el agua ni por
alimentos y que la eficacia de contagio
es baja no obstante la recomendación
general es lavado de manos frecuente con
agua y jabón el uso de gel antibacterial
y estar pendiente de cualquier síntoma y
de si se tuvo contacto con alguna
persona sospechosa de haber contraído
viruela química
y terminamos con deportes el real madrid
conquistó su décimo cuarto título de la
champions league al vencer 1 a 0 al
liverpool en la final del torneo el
encuentro estuvo marcado por retrasos
debido a incidentes que se registraron a
las afueras del stade france en parís
desde la capital francesa nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz con los detalles
el real madrid levantó su orejona número
14 tras vencer un gol por 0 al liverpool
en el estadio de francia aquí en parís
en un estadio que estaba lleno de
estrellas de varios deportes entre ellos
a rafael nadal carlos alcaraz e incluso
ronaldo en todo caso no fue una victoria
con un fútbol muy vistoso pero sí fue
una victoria táctica por parte de los de
carlo ancelotti en un primer tiempo en
el que fueron dominados los merengues en
mayor parte por el liverpool con
llegadas peligrosas no solamente de sala
sino también han de mané pero el real
madrid fue avisando sobre el final de
ese primer tiempo con un gol de benzema
que finalmente fue anulado por estar
fuera de lugar revisión ante el para en
el segundo tiempo en la madrid saltó a
la cancha un poco más ofensivo y sobre
todo también pues movió un poco a las
líneas para que el liverpool no llegara
tan fácil a la portería de activo costó
a sin embargo el real no necesitó sino
de esa esa pequeño ese pequeño opción y
fue en el minuto 59 tras un pase de fe
de valverde a vinicios y vinicios que
encajó el balón en la portería en la
portería
allison y luego vinieron los intentos
completamente frustrados y desesperados
por parte de él el liverpool para tratar
de igualar este partido pero todo fue en
vano finalmente es el madrid quien se
queda con esta victoria pero que en
parte si la portería de lamadrid quedó
en ceros fue gracias a tivo custo a
quizás el mejor jugador de este partido
que evitó todo el tiempo a lo largo de
estos son 90 más a 5 de adición a que el
liverpool a marcará en este partido gran
derrota finalmente para el liverpool que
cuatro años más tarde después de esa
final contra los merengues en kiev no
logra pues sacar esa revancha en final
de liga de campeones
hasta aquí este informativo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]